all right we are live welcome everybody
I'm super excited to be back for another
Google hangout today we're talking about
how to get free media attention for your
business and I have a special guest with
me Andrea Carter she is the public
relations specialist with Aweber and
that's the email software that I use
every day to run my business and we're
gonna answer your questions and talk
about how to get free press for your
company Andrea
welcome aboard hi guys thanks so as I've
been said I'm Andrea Carter I'm the PR
specialist here at Aweber I work on the
marketing team awesome team here I'm
just helping they get media coverage for
the organization I've been doing PR for
close to 10 years I can't believe I'm
saying that
but it'll be 10 in 2016 so I'm really
excited about that
I love PR it's my passion it's what
gives me up every day so I enjoy it so
I'm glad to be here I love it and for
those of you guys watch this as Andrews
very first first so go easy on me I'm a
little bit nervous but let's do it it's
Cochran or cherry for those of you guys
who've been on before you know there's
that box on the right side you can ask
your questions we're going to go through
an order and then you can also comment
on the things that we're talking about
in joining the discussion so there's a
bunch of questions every command you
have but just before getting started
what are your quick thoughts on how a
business should get free media for their
company what are my quick thoughts on
how they should get free media so what I
actually was gonna start out with Emin
was a quote from a book that I recently
read it's actually by Murray Newlands
someone that I know that you're familiar
with I saw they featured you on some of
his columns and everything but I want to
share this quote from the book because I
think it kind of really highlights the
value of public relations and what it
can do for your organization whether
you're just starting out or if you're
already an established organization so
he wrote the business that can influence
the media will win the trust of the
people simply because consumers
typically decide to purchase from brands
they trust and are familiar with and so
for me this pretty much packs a mighty
punch within one sentence of what the
value of public
it's about you getting your name your
your brand your messaging in front of
your target audience so that they become
familiar with you and so that the and so
that they trust you so that's what it's
all about that's what a PR and media
coverage is all about I love it and I
think back to when I was first starting
my company I see I see getting the media
as your opportunity to influence
thousands tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands you know millions of people
all in one shots instead of you having
to go out one by one by one by one by
one to talk to all these people the
reporters are helping you spread that
message for you and if you look at a
magazine or newspaper article or a
website you know you're gonna pay more
attention to the stories or to the ads
write the stories and the stories don't
have to cost you anything where the ads
cost you every time you're trying to
advertise your brand in one of those
journals so it's such a huge way to grow
your business that I've gotten into The
Wall Street Journal and New York Times
and Forbes magazine and especially I
think when you're getting started to add
some credibility to what you're doing
it's just an amazing way to potentially
grow your company so we're gonna talk
about it today we've got a bunch of
questions and we just need to go in
order so guys you can leave the
questions on that chat box first up was
Jay Rhys who is saying Jay Rhys is a
regular contributor always asked the the
non-conventional deeper questions so you
always got to get ready when a giant
clean it off my question is what do you
think of unethically manipulating the
media allow ryan holidays book trust me
I'm lying confessions of a media
manipulator know I didn't know that Jay
rise a little bit of you know Michael
Russell some feathers so but I was going
to actually thank him for putting this
in here before before we actually did
the chat today because I feel like this
is such a loaded question and so many
Lampe potential landmines all around it
I'll say that I'm not I have not read
this book so I can't really speak to
everything that the gentleman says and
within the book but to the question of
you know do i what do I think of
unethically manipulating the media well
well I don't try to condone unethical
practices so I'm going to say that it's
never okay but specifically within
public relations and when you're working
with media is
twice's not okay because here's the
thing the risks that are involved with
going about something in a in a
malicious way a backdoor you know
unethical kind of way the risks are far
greater than any potential media
coverage and what I met what I mean by
that is if that is uncovered you are
gonna have so much of a more difficult
time doing some crisis communications
than you ever would have so hands down
working with the media I would not
suggest doing that at all yeah I would
tend to agree I think I think the only
case you know I think it's based on your
personality I think in general people
are ethical good nice people and that
reflects and everything that you do in
your pockets you create and how you deal
with customers and how you deal with the
media and how you end yourself on social
there are people who build brands for
themselves as being the antagonist as
being the person who you like to hate
and I think that's something that he's
probably done but I think I think it
won't work for most people and you have
to generally be true to who you are and
ideally you're putting out a message of
actually is helpful and contributing to
the lives and businesses of other people
right but but you're right it's oh and
you can always expect the load of
question who terrorized I mean I should
have given you the heads up it's always
started but you pick that you recognize
you're anyway you got it okay next is
helper desk
do you prefer media attention some
offline channels such as newspapers and
magazines or from online such as blogs
and relevant sites to your industry sure
so me doing public relations for the
past 10 years or so is for the more
traditional so those online newspapers
and magazines and things like that but
for me that's just a personal preference
because I've grown up in this and like
back in the day for us to see something
in print that was like a big deal like
oh they actually thought it was that
that good of a story that is actually
printed they spent the money for it and
things like that as saying slowly or
actually quickly progressed to or more
media outlets moving online of course
you still want to go after those as well
my allegiance is still to kind
those traditional media outlets but what
I'm getting at is that at the end of the
day it really doesn't matter though what
your personal preferences it's about
where your audience is so here at Aweber
whether you're you know starting a new
company or or an established company
wherever your target audience is that's
where you're going to go I don't care if
it's a blog I don't care if it's podcast
I don't care if it's the more
traditional media you figure out where
your target audience is what programs
they listen to what things they watch
and you go there that's what you go
after I love it I couldn't agree more
I love it I think to add to it what I
would say I you know that was my answer
it's always harder going second no bad
luck is great like absolutely you got to
know where your audiences and target
just like people figuring out what
social media platform should I go on you
know well where's your audience that's
where you want to be the the thing that
I would add maybe to traditional versus
non-traditional is I think it can also
depend on what your goal is if your goal
is just to get recognition and to get
credibility I think the old-school stuff
still has a little more weight to be
able to say you were in the New York
Times and Wall Street Journal adds a lot
more credibility for most people then
they say you are featured on PewDiePie
is YouTube channel kind of thing
especially if you're dealing with a
business world that you're selling to
but if you want impact I would probably
say it's easier to get the reach by
going online because it's easier to get
to a big youtuber than it is to get to
the editor of a big traditional magazine
or newspaper so I would also in addition
to Angela's point about understanding
what your target audience is I would try
to think about what's the goal is the
goal just to get kind of recognition
credibility is it a credibility
statement for you or are you trying to
just drive more people to your website
and get impact because I think that goal
might impact which way you go but do
both hey you know I embrace the genius
at the end don't do one or the other you
could do both yeah actually that was
something that I was hoping would come
out in the conversation as well like
Media Relations and media coverage media
outreach is just one piece of the puzzle
all these things have to work together
and you have to be strategic about it
but it's not going to be one single
thing that blows you up or you know that
it gets you mass attention all these
things have to work together well yeah I
love it
next we should cut TV another loyal
viewer where's the best place to start
for start-up small business and or new
youtubers thanks Andrea and Evan um so
the first place to start you know
assuming that you've done all your due
diligence of everything that we just
talked about right like you've
identified who your target audience is
you know where they are where they want
to be in things like that there's a
couple things that you could do I would
start by taking a look at your space
that you're in and looking at the media
coverage that other people have gotten
in your space so you can see the types
of articles the types of media that
they've done and then that way you can
also see which reporters are writing
about these things so it's kind of
starting to survey the land if you will
to figure out okay who's talking about
these things that I want to be known for
and then going after those types of
reporters another thing that I would
recommend is I'm a big proponent of
establishing a platform for yourself as
a thought leader within your industry
within you know your expertise and
things like that and so you know once
you identify what your target media
publications media outlets are you know
offer to contribute an article that
showcases your expertise now an article
like this it's not going to be able to
say hey I do this and come purchase my
service or hire me but what it's going
to do is when someone is looking for a
service like yours or is looking for a
product like yours when they go to
Google and those articles start coming
up best believe they're going to see
your name and oh by the way you're going
to be established as a thought leader
for it
another final thing that I would
recommend just kind of quick easy things
that you can do is utilize some of these
free services so help a reporter out I
don't know if you're familiar with it
but I've been using it since I've been
in PR it's a free service you sign up
for and it's basically three daily
emails that reporters is basically media
queries and so it's a whole list of
various reporters who are writing
articles and they're looking for sources
so all I do is comb
and see hey what can a weber comment on
here what are you know with something
that's related to what we do that we can
help this literally help this reporter
out and get an article ran so those are
just some things that I would recommend
just starting out I love it hero is a
great source help a reporter out I think
for anybody who's trying to do that one
understand that you are an expert you
should be right as an entrepreneur you
should be an expert in your industry of
what you do and for every article that
reporters writing they're looking for
experts right you read any article
they're shooting stats and opinion and
then as always some expert quoted right
that should be you for your industry and
hero is a great free resource to use one
I use as well as called PR leads comm
similar I find a little bit higher
quality publications
but there's also a cost it's $99 a month
but I've gotten into New York Times and
Forbes because of it so a good
investment lease from my point of view a
tip for that would be when you're
writing to the reporter you want to you
want to write a story you don't want to
say hey I'm an expert on that happy to
talk to you because they're getting so
many people writing to them right if
they have twenty to a hundred people
writing in to them to say hey I can help
you out they're gonna go to the ones
that provide some value so in that email
will you reach out you want to make sure
you're giving them value and explaining
your thoughts on whatever piece that
they're writing so that makes them want
to call you yeah I would agree with that
and then another one in addition to
Harrow and the one that you mentioned
there's profit I don't know if you're
familiar with profit as well that's also
a paid service but one little trick that
I found though is if you follow the
profit account same for Harrow even
though Harrow it's free but if you
follow the profit net account a lot of
times they'll post a lot of the queries
in Twitter so you can get you know some
free queries right there and see if
there's anything that you can add in I'm
writing this down hold on notice they do
post some of their queries of reporters
who are looking for things and it's free
like it's Twitter so that's cool I like
it I like it I like it one more quick
thought because
she's talking to being a youtuber and
getting the tension as a youtuber do you
have thoughts on on YouTube versus other
marketing channels or is there any
advice would give us specifically to a
YouTube or is it the same no matter what
industry you're in well one of the
things I notice is that you and is it
Rishi you Rishi are are good friends
right so I think what she's doing
already what she's doing already is
pretty smart and that she's you know
networking she's utilizing her network
so that you know for folks who already
have a huge following I don't want to
say necessarily right in the coattails
but you're expanding your network you're
getting the exposure based off of the
network that others have so I think
she's she's doing it already yeah Rishi
she's been a loyal a little viewer as
part of the Master Hung group that I
have to what I would say is I think you
should be really active in the community
that you want to be known in so you know
if you're trying to be a successful
youtuber and you're trying to get
attention I would try to gravitate more
towards collaborations with other
youtubers people already have a youtube
audience I think you could get more
leverage out of that than being featured
in your local newspaper as an example
because how many people reading the
newspaper are kind of daily YouTube
viewers to the point of knowing who your
target audience is that and you're
brought up at the start of the show I
think if you promote well within that
platform and connect with people within
your platform you'll grow much faster
than if you go off platform
none of the out platform stuff doesn't
help I think you just get more success
and results from being in platform yeah
and I think it goes back to what we're
saying it's about you know what your
goals are so you have to identify those
that's one of the main things in order
to be successful with these things you
have to identify what your goals are at
the start it's not enough just to say
hey I want people to know who I am or I
want you know more business you have to
identify specifically where your goals
are your messages so that you can always
stay true to those and refer back to
them so that everything that you do
aligns with those goals I love it
okay next Dennis Wagner if you had to
use only one thing think small budget
small budget to generate massive media
attention what would it be
and why but here's the thing it's a
million there is no one thing like I
cannot stress that enough so Dennis
unless you are best friends with Oprah
Winfrey there is not this one thing that
is gonna you know just catapult you into
mass success it's it like we've been
saying it's a combination of all of
these things working together but you I
mean you have to have good stories so
you know what is the one thing that I
can't live without sure I still use
press releases and that tends to you
know get me a lot of exposure for things
that I do here at a Weber if anybody
tells you the press release is dead
they're lying because it is still very
much alive and it's still you know very
profitable very successful so there's
things like that but the end of the day
it comes back to what is the story that
you're telling and so if the story is
there you trust me you're not gonna have
any problems getting the mess of the
mass coverage and things like that so
it's always going to come back to the
story that you're telling and if your
best friend
Oprah let me know because yeah we'll do
an interview for the Hangout you know
she could be my goodness I'd be great
yeah and we'll have Angie on to it'll be
the three of us I like it okay but to
the to the question of an entrepreneur
an entrepreneur is so busy running their
company right like we're not slackers
we're working 80 hours a week already
just just running our business and now
we're telling people hey you got a this
is important you got to do this - well
like add it to the list of the other 100
things I need to do yeah
pay off what what's the starting point
like where D where would you say someone
like Dennis starts but what's the first
thing they should do just start building
a little bit momentum around this um I
think it goes back Reese's question of
just kind of surveying the land to see
you know in terms of what I want to be
known for and others who are whether
similar to me or what I aspire to be for
my business what kind of media coverage
are they getting but then add on to that
okay what do I bring to the table that's
fresh that's new that's different and
then you know plan your attack and go
from there but it it's always going to
come back
to the story media coverage is not about
hey this is what I do here's what I'm
selling
it's about here's the story here's the
value that it brings to your audience
and then once that story is published
the the bang for the buck that you get
out of it that your name is in there
they will start to familiarize yourself
familiarize themselves with who you are
and what your business is but you got to
have a story have something that's of
interest one of the things that helped
me when I was first getting started was
I made my own media list you know I
didn't have money to go hire somebody to
work for me or an agency I just wanted
to do it myself and I just made a list
of all of the reporters who were
covering my industry and then also my
local area so I'm from Toronto so any
Toronto publication I would I would
cover if I was starting over now I'd
probably expand it to also include the
online media youtubers Twitter people
and every week I would reach out to them
with a new story idea and it wasn't it
wasn't just like a promotional like hey
I've launched a new product it was a
story that I could imagine them
publishing on their website in their
magazine in the newspaper always had a
catchy headline always have a catchy
second headline I'm so glad you said
that that was one thing I wanted to make
sure I mention like when you're thinking
about media coverage think in terms of
headline that's right so you know what
are the headlines that you typically see
and whatever your story idea is could
you picture that as a headline is that
something that you yourself would be
interested in reading if you opened up
the newspaper or a magazine so that's a
really good point think in terms of
headlines yeah and so like if you're
pitching somebody on a YouTube channel
think about what would the name of the
video be called yeah right if you're
pitching somebody for an article in a
newspaper what would the name of that
article be called Yeah right if you can
wow them and get their attention then
they're more likely to read right the
goal of the headline is to get them to
read the sub headline to get them to
read the next paragraph to get them to
continue reading the story so I would I
would do that every every week I would
send that out to my list of a couple
hundred people that I made a list of and
every time I got picked up by somebody
whether it was a radio show whether it
was a newspaper sometimes it would even
just copy and pay
and just print it exactly as is because
they love the story and didn't even tell
me about it
some of them so it really important to
write like a story that you can imagine
appearing on their channel or in their
magazine your newspaper
more than just a pitch of what you do
and some new product from oh cool
much rights in doing a typical pitch to
a journalist or media channel seems
boring have you ever done something
unusual or creative to get coverage from
the media um so I agree that sometimes
it can get boring and if you think about
it I think from the perspective of the
reporters that you're reaching out to
right they are probably receiving
hundreds if not thousands of media
pitches emails a day with story ideas
that quite honestly if you talk to
reporters they say the majority of them
are junk so why not you know to your
point make it a little bit more creative
something that will grab their attention
so one example that I have is last week
was a national customer service week I
don't know if you guys are familiar with
it but here where we are a leader or
weirdo leader in the ESP space for our
customer solutions Department right
we're known for having outstanding
customer solutions so we basically we
took national customer service week and
the fact that we are a leader for
customer service in our space and we
turned that into basically a media idea
things that we can share on our blogs
and things like that but to bring some
life to the story what we did was create
a video and we created a video that
showed our CEO and our CEO talking about
why we're a leader in customers in
customer service what we do here what
customer service means here at Aweber
and then we also showed our CEO and our
CEO L in the customer solutions
department taking calls assisting
customers and things like that and so
what I did was I used that for my media
pitching so it wasn't just hey national
customer service week is this week we're
a leader in customer service so consider
an article from us know it's those
things plus here let me show you let me
bring it to life for you you know and so
that's another way that just kind of mix
things up for them and get a little bit
creative another thing that I would also
recommend speaking to the point of not
just
a basic couple sentence email create
some visuals create infographics create
videos like we said also if you have
data to back up where you're saying or
to support where you are saying
journalist love data so you know get
creative with with how you go about
things and what you send to them to
bring a story to life for them if it's
helping them do their job so I totally
agree that getting creative is something
that you should consider
yeah when looking at that question I
think of PT Barnum who used to have a
circus and he has an elephant to plow
his fields
I love PT Barnum I study up okay well
for those who don't know the story he
there's he'd be this train ride they
would go in and and people would look at
the train and they see this elephant
plow in a field and it just caused he
was a big he was all about the curiosity
and people would then want to know like
what's happening here and and he would
always milk as much as he could from
publicity but never the typical like
boring pitches is always something
different I think the modern day is like
Richard Branson who drives to New York
City on a tank and like jet skis in and
repels down buildings and he makes big
events out of things I haven't done
anything anywhere close to that I'm I
think and most people I think are super
boring and tame in comparison but
there's a kiss Rubin to improve their
the closest thing that I've done that
was different was when I was just
getting started in this business I was
what 22 years old and I felt like I was
in no name I didn't have a lot of
credibility I was young people would
look at me like what I'm gonna learn
from this guy who's too young so I put
together what I called the guide to
professional success and I contacted a
whole bunch of really well-known font
leaders like Anthony Robbins and Brian
Tracy and Zig Ziglar and kind of the
leaders at the time and got I said here
I want to create this guy from freshman
success I'm gonna have it as a free
download off my website can I use this
article and it was an article they had
written from their newsletter online
somewhere
and I got permission from them to be
able to use that article and I combined
all of the articles together and then I
added mine in there as well so there's
like Evan with all of these big names
and so it started adding kind of more
instant credibility and people in the
media picked up on it because it was
kind of different so they're interested
in reading it sharing it and it got me
my first kind of like hint of excitement
from the media okay well I think overall
I'm pretty boring and maybe it's a good
challenge it's a good challenge much to
do something there anything right a tank
through Toronto or something bungee jump
from the CN Tower to support
entrepreneurs or something I like it
though it's good it's a good challenge
um xeno writing in do you think there's
such a thing as bad publicity
I understand media attention can be very
helpful but do you think there are ways
in which it can hurt things you would
want to avoid so I do think there is
such thing as bad publicity now do you
think that there are ways that it can
hurt the immediate example that comes to
mind for me is Donald Trump right so a
lot of what we're seeing right now from
him yeah he's all over the place he's
kind of dominating the news coverage in
terms of the election right now but a
lot of people are also picking up on and
pointing out the fact that some of his
comments you know can be offensive or
they rub people the wrong way and he's
consistently doing it a time after time
after time and so a lot of people are
saying and thinking that this is
eventually going to hurt him and so it's
great that there is you know a lot of
media coverage that he's getting but
consistently you know offending people
and things like that now don't get me
wrong you got to take a stand on things
and media people like that but when you
kind of cross that line where you're no
longer respectful to people and doing
that consistently I think you run into
issues where you know it could be
detrimental instead of actually helping
you so that's just one example that came
to mind for me when I saw that question
yeah I have mixed feelings on it you
know I wonder if you asked Donald Trump
you know what he would feel like is that
hurting his brand or not because he is
getting an insane amount of coverage and
I'm sure a lot of people now hate him
because of the
but then do people to his supporters
people feel the same way now love him
and get more exposure because of it I
don't know I'm on the fence the one the
idea that came to my mind was Rob Ford
who was our Mayor of Toronto I don't
know if you the name means anything he
did a whole bunch of kind of really
stupid things in the media and and it
put Toronto on the map for a while in
the u.s. is a lot of times you know
Canadian stuff isn't covered that much
but it was in a negative way right it
wasn't it wasn't put it in a in a
positive light and I was just hearing
yesterday on the radio talking about the
Blue Jay game we're in the next round go
Jays go and they're still referencing
Rob Ford like all Toronto is known for
is the Blue Jays now and and Rob Ford
and I love my city and it's kind of I
feel like it's an it's a stain as much
as he put it on the map it's also you
put on them up a negative way so I don't
know I I have mixed feelings on it I
don't have a great answer on that but
yeah I mean you kind of never know how
it's going to shake down and so to your
point about Trump it could well still
have to wait and see right if it's
either going to hurt them or if it's
going to help him but in your case like
the example that you were given that you
were giving you're right you know once
something like that happens it's kind of
hard to separate yourself from that once
that bad news is out there so to the
question of whether or not media
coverage can in some way have the
potential to be a bad thing it can
because they can you know almost tattoo
your brain for people with your brand is
so I think it can be a detrimental thing
yeah I think so in terms of what's the
advice like so this is a question but
then what's what's the advice that you
would give to an entrepreneur
around that around just avoiding or cuz
I mean you I don't have an easy answer
for how to avoid it because I guess that
on the one hand you don't necessarily
want to play everything safe you have to
take a stand right so I guess my advice
is almost what you were saying before of
know who you are and stay true to who
you are don't do something just for this
think of trying to get
olicity or because you know it's gonna
be controversial and get everybody's
eyes on you if that's not who you are
then I would say don't do it so identify
who you are what you want to be known
for and stick to that and just tell your
story yeah so like would you give Trump
advice to like to tone down to say
listen dude I think with Trump is that
yeah that is who he is but my advice to
him is to tone it down and to consider
the fact that listen you know you're
running for a presidency and especially
for a title for a position like that
right we're talking about an entire
country where the the votes that you
want this is that diverse set of people
so offending people rubbing people the
wrong way you got to kind of take it
easy so yeah I would just advise that he
tones it down just a little bit look I'm
gonna cool interesting interesting
uh-huh okay next Sherri I help start and
volunteer for Park watch for our 700
acre park there's going to be a huge
write-up and pictures of us in the paper
is there a way to incorporate my
business name discreetly um I think I
just need to know a little bit more here
in terms of incorporating your business
name so I just need to know if you want
if you are going to incorporate your
business name and how your business is
associated with it like there has to be
a natural connection between the two and
it has to add to the story so whatever
your business is and in relation to the
door and in relation to the program that
you started what is the connection how
do the two work together to tell a story
outside of that I can't really think of
a way to have just slide in your
business name for the sake of you know
knowing that there's going to be media
coverage for it it has to add to the
story yeah I would thinking the exact
same thing what might be helpful is
understanding the purpose behind it like
as part of the story that the media is
covering why did you do this that you
started and organized this why was it so
important for you to put this on right
why is Park watch that's an important
part of your community and then that is
something that the media would want to
quote write like it was started by this
person and they're sharing your opinions
and off
they'll put in cherry from whatever
company to add some context to it but I
agree it has to be part of you know if
you could tie in your whatever your
company does if if looking after the
community is part of it like if running
your business
and you want it to give back was part of
it like if you can tie that into the
story I agree like that's the best way
to do it otherwise it feels like a pitch
and they're not gonna they're not gonna
say yes to it just to kind of piggyback
on that do you have thoughts on how
entrepreneurs can use I get this truck
all right like I want to give back it's
charity I want to help whether they're
organizing something or donating to
something or just spending their time
somewhere do you have feedback on how
they might be able to feel good about
themselves but then also get some
promotion and use it for for publicity
um I think it goes back to what we were
just saying if you if you if you are
doing it like you're helping about a
charitable organization and some kind of
way it relates to your business it all
it always has to add value to the story
it has to tell the total story so that's
really the only recommendation that I
have for that got it
yeah it's so like maybe the add to it
some things I think it might be to ask
if you can be put on their website right
so looking if one you link in to them
and showing what you do in the community
could be great for your website if
clients come to you and say you know so
I'm looking to anywhere say I'm looking
at doing I'm buying some I need email
marketing software for my company right
and I hear what a Weber here but other
guys I go to eight Weber's website and
there's a story about how they were
giving back to their local community
that makes me feel a little bit closer
to a Weber I'm more likely to wanna sign
up with them versus somebody else and so
yeah like same thinking for you if you
could share this store on your website
that adds credibility and just a feel
goodness to making me want to work with
you I know that's a word make it up and
then I would try to get a link from
their site as well want that helps you
with your SEO which will help you with
your business but also anybody visiting
that website it says hey it's supported
by a Weber supported by you know Harry
you're supported by whoever
and it it puts the brand in there and
they while some may click throw on it to
say hey I'm curious to know who's
supporting these guys and the media
might also be curious to know hey who's
supporting these guys so that could also
help also may be a story that just you
know if you believe that businesses
should be giving back like if that's
part of what you're all about that could
be a story in itself and that you're
challenging other businesses to stand up
and give back and you know you're doing
it in your own small way by doing this
thing and other companies doing it in
the bigger way but just issuing a
challenge to other entrepreneurs to hey
B want to fix up our community
entrepreneurs have a responsibility to
give back and help out that could be a
story in itself that gets attention for
you but also there's a story and the
benefits the community and the
publication that that is receiving this
I'm going to make sure I share with
people when you're thinking about media
coverage and you're thinking about ideas
to Evans point it's not always just
about your business and what you do like
I started out by saying you know you're
telling a story but really the goal is
to get your name your branding in front
of people so they become familiar and
recognize who you are but you can do
that in ways similar to what Evan just
said so as you're thinking about story
ideas think about these human-interest
things right think about ways that you
know if you're helping individuals or
things like that just think about things
that will appeal to people as humans
because that's the thing we're all human
and so we all have these things these
same thoughts these same once the same
you know how come there isn't somebody
who's doing this if you're thinking it
is nine times out of ten somebody else
is thinking it too so if you can take
that thing and turn it into a story that
works for your business goals you're
going to have success I love it you know
go ahead not I have a totally tangent
thought I just found an interesting we
we both match our backgrounds I'm black
on black and you're on purple that's
like the question of that is I wonder if
you had tips for headlines so if you are
now
pitching this are there some general
rules we talk about the importance of
headlines do you have general tips on
what makes a good headline sub-headline
that that people watching here can take
home and set the implement sure
headlines that relate to something of
human human interest if you have stats
and they show something that is either
counter intuitive or you know something
that would surprise people stats are
always good a lot of people like the the
tips of things so like these listicle
type things so if you have an idea for
something list out the five ways that
your business brings that value again
you're not selling your business but
here's why it's the value and what
people should be thinking about so those
are like some of the headlines that you
could think about I love it I remember
one of the early press releases I did
was I went to the City of Toronto
website and looked at how many
entrepreneurs were being created every
year and I turned that into a story to
say X number thousand entrepreneurs
created this year in Toronto and I got
picked up by a radio show and a local TV
station a local magazine just fun taking
a number from the City of Toronto
website like it was publicly available
information that I just turned into a
story and people picked up on it so here
at Aweber we do try to keep track of our
stats and you know what our customers
are doing in terms of their use of email
marketing so that if I go to pitch a
story I can say something like you know
email marketing is a value for this
reason but then I have the stats to
support it as well journalists will eat
that up because it's hard numbers we
have the the customer base and the huge
numbers to back it up and to show it
love it cool Nick I'm running a social
project to help refugees and physically
challenged individuals get back into
employment what can I do to get the
media to help me um to help you so this
one I would probably go along the lines
of what we're seeing a human-interest
type thing but for the folks that you
are helping get some testimonials so
give some people that you have helped
and tell that story right so it's not
just about hey this is what I do but
here is an actual
person who I of health who was a refugee
or what have you and they went from this
point at that point there now there's
now employed again so give some of those
stories that you can share with the
media that'll definitely help
yeah I agree I would I think I would
lean towards making it about not about
you but making about the individual
people that you help and you will be a
natural byproduct of that story right
like they came to this country and then
they met you and then they got a job
right so that's something that's
powerful the other angle that I might go
with is just using some stats to call
out the government or to call out the
public sector or the private sector to
say we should be doing more to help
these people
so like X number people come to this
country every year as refugees and why I
can't find no Y number of people can't
find jobs and are ending up you know
doing whatever right if you could
compile those stats and then you have
yourself as a thought leader to comment
on those stats what that means then I
think that could be a pretty powerful
story as well that people would want to
pick up on I mean we always hear in the
news talk about the unemployment rates
and things like that so for this
business it could be okay we got the
news that the national average
unemployment rate is X but did you know
of that unemployment rate of that number
X amount are you know refugees or things
like that and then you kind of piggyback
off of existing news that people are
already talking about but like I was
saying before you add a new perspective
to the story you bring a fresh
perspective that people either aren't
considering and hadn't thought about
and there's your news yeah and speaking
about piggybacking I would use what's
happening in the media right now right
so now election if you're in the US it's
election election every time you hear on
the news something new about the
election that's gonna happen for a while
all right we're still a while when is
the actual election day I November right
is it only November I thought it was I
thought it was like next year no oh
you're right you're right I'm sorry
go ahead I should know this but go ahead
I don't know but it's gonna happen for
like the elections in America
insanely long processes this first you
have to win for your party and then you
have to go through the election that's
like this long drawn-out thing which
which is great because it's in the media
a lot and you can easily piggyback off
of those things so are any of the
candidates talking about this in any way
good or bad you agree or disagree right
and then that becomes a story right we
talk about Donald Trump so Donald
Trump's view on refugees I don't know
what it is
maybe it's a great one that you agree
with maybe it's a one that you
absolutely despise and hate but as soon
as you start talking about Donald
Trump's view on something it's much more
likely to get picked up and then you're
like the opposing opinion or you're the
supporting opinion and so if you can
piggyback off any of the candidates
whoever's being talked about the most
it's a great way to be able to draw
attention to your cause yep cool
Sherry's asking about smoothies I
mentioned the shout outs I was making
smoothies she asked if it's from my
wife's garden I don't know what's in
this one it's if it's red it's beats the
Martins gone though the garden is gone
it's it's October it's Canada man Tamara
how could I tell the story of Mika with
cerebral palsy how can you tell the
story of her I don't is that is that a
trending I feel like it is it a personal
thing it's a personal thing I think it's
a personal thing so I mean I guess it's
fine what is the story yeah yeah you
have to figure out what the angle is but
the angle being you so and we keep kind
of going back to the same points right
it's a matter of what your goals are for
your business or or what it is that you
want to accomplish by telling this
person's story and so whatever that is
you kind of craft a story around that so
if she you know is overcoming obstacles
or things like that you can build a
story around these things that would be
interesting to people but you have to
start with knowing you know what you
want to accomplish when somebody sees
this story or hears the story or reads
about it or something like that
is it that you want them to do and you
have to kind of craft the story in a way
that gets that message in there so
unfortunately I don't know more about
this story or what it is that she's
seeking to accomplish but I'm sure
there's like a human ancient human
interest angle there or something of
that sort that you could use yeah and
back to Angie's point from like the very
top of the show but knowing your
audience there may be multiple ways to
bring this out by pitching different
stories at different channels right so
you know I'm an entrepreneur channel
does Mika do anything entrepreneurship
of any inches of entrepreneurship you
know if they watch an entrepreneur video
does make a get all excited
I'm just thrown examples you know you
could partner up with a piano channel
maybe meet this learn to play piano and
it's a special engine you know like
whatever whatever Micah's hobbies
interests are those could all be
potential resources for you to connect
with people in those channels to draw
attention to what's happening so yeah so
like multiple stories for multiple
publications and channels sorry yet
something else to add on that okay we're
riffing I like it
Lucy B was it a dumb idea to have my
press release released press release
released on a Friday okay so there is no
magic day but I do try to stay away from
Fridays and the reason being that you
know it's a Friday a lot of people tend
to take their vacations on Fridays
things of that nature
so here when we send out a press release
we normally go on like a Monday or a
Tuesday so what I say it was dumb no I
wouldn't say that but I do try to stay
away from Fridays just for the reasons
you know of people taking vacations or
taking a long weekend or something like
that and it's also like the end of the
week people are kind of checked out and
people not as many people may see your
news or see your news release things
like that but earlier in the week it's
kind of like retuned in like we're ready
for the week what's the news things like
that we're checking our emails checking
to see what's going on in the news so I
would try to stick to the earlier half
of the week yeah
so it's greatly and Luci you know like
Congrats on getting that press release
out that maybe your first one and good
you know you learn you keep going you're
gonna make lots of mistakes as you grow
and you've got some wisdom from Angie
right here now and so the next one that
comes out earlier on in the week yeah I
find you know tests test right you have
your list you have your topics you send
it out you test you see what works yeah
you know we're talking about Aweber I
tested an insane number of combinations
to find out what the best day and time
to send up my email newsletters were and
for me it's Wednesdays at five in the
morning so that's what they send out my
autoresponders go out at Wednesday at
five in the morning because that's when
people will open it up has the highest
open race and so the bigger data set you
have the more you can test so if you
have a list of newspapers or you're
reaching out to our youtubers or if
you're doing email marketing you know
use your stats to see what works and
then continue to improve I mean
definitely use best practices the next
test is try Wednesday see how that works
for you or try to write that you're
bringing up Evan which is you know not
only the testing but just making sure
that you're monitoring and measuring
especially for i'm small business owners
and entrepreneurs because you're just
starting out with your media coverage
start measuring these things early
figuring out what works and what doesn't
if you get media coverage and it drives
a lot of traffic to your to your website
or something you know what works right
and keep iterating off of that and keep
doing more of it so constantly monitors
to see what is working so that you can
do more love it next question could you
please clearly spell out the resources
you mentioned Harrow PR leads PROFINET
others so lists of the resources yet so
I used help a reporter out the acronym
for is har o you can sign up for that
it's a free service you'll get three
emails per day with media queries from
reporters who are writing about stories
profit is something that I used when I
was this was two jobs ago I worked at a
university
and so it's similar to Harrow but it is
a paid service but like I was saying to
Evan I found that if you just follow
them on Twitter I doubt they're putting
all of the queries but they are putting
some of them so just get them and your
in your Twitter feed so you can see if
there's something that you could
possibly respond to another one that I
didn't mention but this is just for
press releases press release
distribution one free service is PR log
it's PR and then the word log L o G and
I think it's just PR allowed that work
but that's the service that you can use
to send press releases for free press
release wire distributions they tend to
be a little bit expensive but PR log is
one that I've used in the past that's
free love it and so thank you for that
and I think what I'm gonna do is once
the video is done I'll add those in the
description so for everybody who is
interested you guys can check it out
there and and if we if we come with any
more along the way question what is
Andrews Twitter handle my twitter handle
PR because I love CR so she loves it's
about Lu vs and then the letters PR she
loves PR
Angie's Twitter handle is already in the
descriptions if you check in there and
also her about me so you can find out
more about all of her links on social
and follow her what is the best place
for advertising TV YouTube somewhere
else again I know I'm beating a drum
here but where is your audience so it's
hard for me to say this is the best
medium or this has the best return
because it's all about where your
audience is that one I I honestly it's
hard for me to say so I'm a my
background is in public relations as
opposed to more of the ad buys and
things like that so Evan I don't know if
there's something that you can add here
to that because I'd be hesitant to give
my advice will probably be wrong honest
answers that's what it's all about I
love it what I
would say is you know anytime you're
spending money you gotta be really
careful right because you can drop money
on advertising super quick and drain
your budget and not get any results so
small tests are always the best way to
go I would test online first because
it's cheaper and you can get fast
results you know doing a TV commercial
that's not cheap that's not cheap just
to buy the time but also to produce the
actual message right the content is mega
expensive so I would start online you
can do fairly inexpensive Facebook ads I
think if your new advertising faith
Facebook is probably the best way to go
because of the targeting you know you
can say I want people who are Christian
who live in Oregon and like the Toronto
Blue Jays right like you can figure that
out and advertise just to those people
and so if you know the type of customers
that you're trying to go after if you
can get that specific then it's much
easier to market to them and so you can
use dark posts to be able to get to them
I just probably your best bet you can do
other you could do Twitter ads you can
do YouTube ads you can do StumbleUpon
ads but I would probably start Facebook
and test test test test test what andrew
is talking before tests us the defender
Asians see what works and then expand
but I'd be super concerned about just
dropping budget into something because
it's it's so easy to waste your money on
advertising and not get a response yeah
how do you go back to associations that
you work with before but the founder has
passed away he was a huge contact are we
talking about but it's I mean so you
take that question if you're trying to
go back to a client you work with before
or even a media outlet you've worked
with before a group you volunteer with
before that's you know the CEO or the
head was a really important contact for
you and now they're gone you know it's
like you've got into New York Times and
now that contact of yours is gone how do
you get back in and develop a new
relationship I think it's about
developing those new relationships and
so you know bring
the value to the table one person may be
gone but although that person is gone it
doesn't mean the value of whatever
you're bringing to the table is gone so
it's just a matter of you know working
the network within establishing those
new relationships and then still letting
the new relationships that you are that
you were forming letting them know what
value you're bringing to the table and
just establishing new ones yeah I would
I mean to add to that I would one not
you've learned this valuable an
important lesson for the next time you
know make more than one contact or at an
organization so know you've learned a
hard lesson ongoing now when you're
dealing with future clients you want to
learn who the people are under them that
might take over so you know you have
that lesson learned too though there's
got to be people in your organization
who would know you right if you work
with the CEO and and and/or the head of
the Association and they were a huge
contact and the big supporter there has
to be somebody in the organization who
knows about you who work with them who
you work with on some projects it's kind
of super rare to you know head of
organizations like to delegate and bring
on teams it's super rare to have
somebody working only with them with
zero external contact so I'd be looking
at who else in the company in the
association you might know even if it's
not the right person that would hire you
or work with you again but they would
know your name and understand the value
that you can bring to them and reach out
whether it's a coffee whether there's a
phone call so with an email I just sit
down with them and try to understand
where the organization is going if they
could be of any potential assistance to
you get to know them a little bit more
there's got to be some people in our
organization that could that would if
you show up would remember your name and
your face yeah okay we did the Twitter
handle holy cow the question we're short
on time guys the questions are instantly
is there a way yeah that's good and you
were not enough question so you get lots
of questions e the nation is turning up
is there a way to actually talk to
Andrea or past Aweber hosts to help with
starting out with Aweber
oh yeah absolutely so I don't know if
some of my colleagues are in the chat
but my contact information is there and
I mean I don't mind giving out my email
address it's Andrea's see at a Weber
dot-com so feel free to shoot me an
email and then in terms of getting you
started trying out our service where
I'll absolutely be able to point you in
the right direction
cool yeah I mean from my experience
everybody in Weber has been super
helpful even if they're not the person
to talk to you they'll kind of like
point you in the right direction you
just call it in honestly they've got a
phone line just calling you're gonna get
some pretty friendly
exactly yeah yeah so so that's great if
you want to get started you can reach
out there is also a link in the
description about getting started you
can follow that too for more information
yeah next question how does
word-of-mouth relate to the PR it
relates because if you get that media
article you get that news coverage that
you're looking for people will start
talking and then not only will people
start talking they will start tweeting
and then they start retweeting and it
just kind of balloons from there so as
we were saying before all of these
things work together in terms of your
media outreach that you're doing the
coverage that you're getting but then
it's also your marketing if you're going
to do paid advertising it's your social
it's your email marketing so all of
those things work together so one thing
that I would also say since we're
talking about how all this works
together and starts to spread is I'm at
Aweber we're an email marketing company
right and so say you get some news
coverage you can share that with your
email audience in your newsletters let
them know the media coverage that you're
getting that is to get people talking
and spreading the word so make sure all
of these things work together whether
it's in the inbox it's on social or
what-have-you it's just getting the name
out there in front of people so that
they recognize you and they start
talking I love it we go rapid-fire
because I know we're short
Bendre know how I can reach journalists
in Stockholm here in Stockholm it's so
hard
Swedish media not too open-minded as
Americans I must be honest any ideas
Andrea disaster yeah too many of the
reporters out there but just kind of
like we were saying before figure out
which ones that you are interested in or
where you want to be covered and those
reporters that are covering the things
that you want to be known for figure
just look at them and do your homework
so that's one thing I didn't mention
right do your homework in terms of the
types of articles that these reporters
do so that when you go to them you
already know what their style of article
is what kind of reports that they
typically write about that would be of
interest to them so you're kind of going
into the conversation or into the media
pitch with a little bit of knowledge
already that can only help yeah I was in
saying even though wasn't that me I was
gonna answer this thing just look at how
they're already writing articles and
then model that to then create write if
you're if you're like this crazy
American and nobody wants to listen you
because you know your crazy ideas and
Stockholm was so different than the rest
of the world then look at what they're
doing and how can you model that to
think of the straw written about you I I
agree
Steve is writing what are three great
ways to advertise yourself three great
ways to advertise yourself through media
coverage would be like I was saying
before just establishing a platform for
yourself as as a thought leader
so byline articles I'm really really big
one though so it's getting your
expertise out there letting people know
what you do and what you're known for
I'm in a way that brings value to the
audience but it also gets your name and
your message out there I guess also like
I was saying before make sure that all
these things work together so if you
have an email marketing audience that
you're sharing your messages with let
them know like that you're getting
things in you know media because that
adds that third party credibility so
just kind of let them know let your your
different audiences know what you're
doing for a third one what's the
question again Evan tell me what go back
I moved on let's go Steve what are three
great ways to
advertise was the exact question oh I
think you said no no I added that I am
at that but it's not question it's three
great ways to advertise oh all right
well you want to give the third one down
I thought after yourself I'm curious
because I added that so what's do
yourself what are you gonna say to
yourself a blog or something so right so
that you're able to showcase your
expertise that's something that I just
started on because I'm trying to elevate
my platform as well as someone who is
expert and in PR and things like that
right so I'm creative blog and so one of
the things that I was able to do was
with my blog I wrote a blog post and it
was about something that was going on in
the news media and what do you know a
Herald query came through and they were
looking for something that I wrote about
on my blog and I was able to share that
with them and they use some of it so you
know create almost like this this space
that shows your expertise that people
can refer to and they can go to it and
see it anytime that they want you know
we got a named out the blog now so it is
very very new um and it's not even like
officially launched or anything yet
but it the website is the PR maverick so
it's you know just as though it's the PR
maverick and so you'll see all about me
what I do here at a Weber and then just
my thoughts on PR who's doing it good
who's doing it badly and well let's talk
about it
so PR amacom Lukie remember calm okay
okay I've got guys in the description
after so you guys can check it out
awesome where we're at we're at the time
this is great thank you and oh my
goodness it is over it was a lot of fun
though I really really enjoyed the
questions so this was a really really
good time before we go though Evans so I
saw a tweet that you put out the other
day and it was about the entrepreneur
champion of the I'm sorry you know the
entrepreneur champion of the day like it
was another
ESP Evan so I just had to show you
because we're talking about you know
news coverage and breaking news and
everything this here I don't know if you
can see it but this is the crown we are
the reigning we're the reigning
champions for ESP so just make sure
you make that known when you're talking
about champions in the ESP space
Aweber is the champion and in the esv
space okay I love it put on the cam to
it the matches it matches everything I
love it boom awesome so thank you Andrew
so much for your time thank you guys for
watching all your questions and you can
check out all the resources underneath
and we'll see you again next month with
another awesome YouTube hanger thanks
Andrea guys thank you thank you